absolutely mind-bogglingly brilliant i
can't quite believe what i was seeing
emma radacano the 18 year old qualifier
from bromley now the new us open
champion um and surely british sports
next big superstar i can't think of any
narratives in sport quite like it she
had to win three matches in qualifying
to eden get into this tournament to even
earn the right to be here she's now won
seven matches in the main draw she's now
the first british female grand slam
champion for 44 years the last time we
saw it was virginia wade in 1977 nobody
nobody expected emma radhakanu to be
lifting this us open trophy this evening
that's two weeks ago of course as she's
gone through this tournament she's
gained fans she's gained plaudits she's
been utterly dominant just as she was
today she's beaten leila fernandez the
fellow teenager the 19 year old canadian
six four six three she had three
championship points emma adakanu and on
the third championship point she
converted it with an ace she fell to the
floor she's now embracing what's a
relatively small support team here in
new york her coach her physio her agent
her parents are watching back home um in
south london unable to travel because
of the kobe travel restrictions of
course but an utterly joyous moment for
emma adakanu surely one of the all-time
great stories in sport
martha what's been so remarkable uh
about this is that she's just managed to
brush all her opponents
aside despite
her her age
and the fact that really she wasn't a
household name
she was
outside of season tennis watchers she
was virtually unknown three months ago
before she got that wild card through to
wimbledon she was the world ranked 338
when she got that wild card to wimbledon
she said that her aim by the end of this
year was to be in the top 100 um in
order to get access automatically for
the australian open at the start of next
year she certainly didn't expect that
she'd be the us open champion i don't
think anyone did but then no one knew
quite how talented she was before this
tournament she got right through to the
fourth round of wimbledon she had to
withdraw from that fourth round match
with um breathing problems sun then
questioned her mental fortitude my oh my
has she proved the doubt is wrong this
past two weeks as she's come through
qualifying as she's come through the
main draw and she's won the u.s open
title the first ever qualifier to do so
and she's done it without dropping a set
it's been her composure throughout both
on and off the court the completeness of
her game and layla fernandez really
pushed her particularly in that first
set but emma adakanu came up with all
the answers the 18 year old from bromley
a quite astonishing performance and i
think everyone's just excited to see
what she can do next she really does
look like a future world number one a
future multiple grand slam winner she's
already got the first one under her belt
and martha uh if you can still hear me
uh it is inspirational stuff isn't it
what's she
done already for british tennis
i think already i was speaking to
someone from the lta they were saying
you know they expect there to be
hundreds thousands more young girls um
signing up with their local tennis club
and remember emma adakanyu started out
at bromley tennis club and in fact her
coach the the man in her in her box
today andrew robertson a six foot seven
former davis cup player he first met
radhikane who was an 11 year old at
bromley tennis club um and recognized
her potential perhaps didn't dare to
think that one day she'd be a grand slam
winner and certainly not this soon but i
think british tennis and needs to take
advantage of the huge amount of
excitement around emma and radhakanu the
fact that you've got families
prime time saturday night watching a
woman playing tennis is quite
astonishing that amount of excitement
needs to be built upon in order to get
more girls in the game in order to
increase the strength and depth
particularly of the women's game i think
in the past we've seen young players
overhyped perhaps by the media or by a
public that starved of seeing genuine
grand slam contenders but certainly emma
radhakanu as if there was any doubt left
is the real deal she is absolutely
sensational and completely nervous as
well this evening